hi there and welcome to the future of
documents a new series from google cloud
to help developers make the most out of
their unstructured data with document ai
my name is holt skinner i'm a developer
advocate for google cloud and i'll be
helping you throughout this journey
the world's businesses rely heavily on
documents to convey information think of
all the pdfs emails forms and contracts
that you interact with on a daily basis
there's an enormous amount of data in
these files the problem with this type
of data is that it is unstructured or
dark data
dark data is information that businesses
collect process and store during regular
activities but generally fail to use for
other purposes
in other words businesses are sitting on
a document goldmine full of data that
could be used to automate processes or
gather analytics if it could be
extracted into a machine-readable format
let's take a look at the ways companies
can begin to structure this data there
are three methods currently used to
extract data from documents
first we have manual data entry humans
read the documents and then manually
enter that data they see into a system
this requires a significant time
investment and is prone to mistakes
next there are semi-automated solutions
applications can parse documents have a
fixed layout and then extract the text
using optical character recognition or
ocr technology this method can be
effective but it's limited in the types
of documents that can be processed
the third option is to analyze documents
and extract information using artificial
intelligence and machine learning
aiml technology has progressed rapidly
in the last few years and it's now
possible to use it to read documents
parse the content and extract valuable
information from many different document
types this helps remove much of the data
entry toil and can reduce document
processing time
running these applications in the cloud
also allows for flexible scalability as
the volume of documents changes document
understanding is an incredibly complex
field in machine learning because it
combines a lot of different techniques
and algorithms for example ocr image
recognition natural language processing
entity extraction machine translation
and data loss prevention just to name a
few
and this is where document ai comes in
doc ai is google cloud's managed service
to turn your unstructured content into
structured data
document ai is an end-to-end cloud-based
platform for document processing not
only does it read and adjust your
documents it understands the spatial
structure of the document
for example if you run a general form
through a form parser it recognizes
there are questions and answers in your
form and you'll get those back as key
value pairs we'll dive into the details
in a later video
with this data in a structured format
you can begin to make it useful maybe
you want to run analytics on customer
feedback maybe you're processing large
multi-page application forms or maybe
you're trying to add more data sources
to your dashboards
you can easily incorporate document data
into your applications simply by calling
an api no data science expertise
required
now let's break down the main categories
of document ai
there is general doc ai which is
designed to work with just about any
document you can throw at it this
includes ocr a structured form parser
and document quality analysis
for specialized document ai google has
pre-built models for common business
document types we have models for
standardized forms such as w-2s driver's
licenses etc and we have models for high
variance document types such as invoices
and receipts
google trains and maintains the general
and specialized models so you don't have
to
soon the platform will also offer the
ability to build models for your own
document types you'll be able to train
custom models from scratch or uptrain
existing models without having to write
any machine learning code
in this video we talked about how
document ai can help you make sense of
your data so that you can go from
unstructured or dark data to useful
structured data using ai
in the next video we'll explore how to
start using document ai processors with
the cloud console and api then we can
start digitizing and getting insights
from our documents if you'd like to get
started you can go to the document ai
code labs linked in the description for
step-by-step guides
thanks for tuning in and don't forget to
like and subscribe
[Music]
you